my first thought when i heard the news
was
for the family and this is like
every other funeral and
distinct from every other funeral it's
like every other funeral because the
family is the family is the family
and it's distinct because they are
having to bear
this loss and sorrow in the glare
of goodness knows how many people
watching them around the world
and it's interesting what you say there
it's like every other funeral but
like every other funeral taking place in
such
unusual times and these restrictions
under which it has to take place
i think that's a and it's wonderful i
mean the
the royal family i think uh has behaved
superbly in saying
i'm sure if they'd said well you know
this is the head of state we have to do
things a bit differently
but they've just kept to the rules and
that means that they're going through
what our best guess is between six and
eight million other people
have gone through in this country alone
over the last
year which is not really being able to
say
goodbye in the way they'd hoped or
planned
and that is
that's an extra burden but
as they as we watch them tomorrow as
people around the world watch them
tomorrow i think they can identify
with this and feel that here is a
funeral that represents all funerals in
a wonderful way
well we can imagine it already and
you're going to witness it with your own
eyeballs her majesty the queen
sitting on her own masked and on her own
[Music]
yes i'm i never
fail to be
admiring of the way her majesty behaves
i i it's been one of the greatest
privileges of this role is to get to
know her a little bit but she will be
sitting on
her own and masked it would never cross
her mind to complain about that
she will reflect and she will show her
normal
dignity composure and it it's
people will make all kinds of judgments
looking up at her about what she's
thinking
we can't do that you can't do that at
any funeral you never know what people
are thinking
all we know is that this is the queen
who's
served us so extraordinarily for
nearly 70 years saying goodbye
to the man who has been in her words her
strength and stay
for all those years and three years
beyond it
let's talk about that man something
about his character and i i listened
to your tribute to him in the house of
lords and uh
you came up with a word that i hadn't
actually realized i mean i was
privileged once to be
in the same room as him and you
mentioned
energy ah isn't that interesting you
pick that up
i just
we all know everyone seeing this will
think of someone that when they come
into a room
somehow they bring a bit of oomph into
the room
and i my experience was
he was just one of those people i
i said in other places he
i think he was totally incapable of
being boring
he just couldn't do boring
and um one of the stories i heard of him
going to a school and
having to do an impromptu chat to
a bunch of uh students in their
teens and just absolutely having them in
the
palm of his hand because he had that
energy and
commitment and vision and
that is a huge thing to lose and he was
a deep thinker
let's talk about theologically you must
have had discussions with him about the
nature of faith
well yes um
i said in the house of lords that one of
the rights of passage in your early
years as a bishop is you get invited to
sandringham
to preach uh in january
normally with a barbecue on the saturday
evening which
in north norfolk in january is is um
and um and then over you preach on the
sunday morning and you have lunch with
them
the experience is is
really of being put on the spot
perfectly
politely i mean not aggressively but
what do you mean by this
and so and so wrote this and how do you
respond to that
and have you looked at it this way
and he draws on his
or he drew on his
decades of experience across the world
with other faiths
with deep reading and profound
thinking to explore usually at greater
depth than most of us had done in the
sermon
and just back to the nature what we do
know the nature of particularly the of
the procession
and of the service it's itself we talked
about it taking place in this these
awful times of
of coronavirus and all the restrictions
taking place but in part
they do chime with the way the duke
himself and we know he was involved with
the planning of it because he wanted
no fuss he was more than involved in the
planning of it
it was he was involved in every detail
of it
it is meticulously planned for over a
quarter of a century
and when the order of service is seen
his imprint will be all over it and
he didn't want to fuss and he knew
exactly what he wanted and it was
thoughtful
and i think that people listening to
this service
watching it on the tv will find it
speaks
very deeply to their own hearts as so
many will be thinking about
the brother they lost the the parent
they lost the child the
sister whoever it was and they will find
that this
speaks to them of the love of god of the
hope of the resurrection
of the beauty of the world around us of
the gift we have in life
in funerals you do three things you look
back
and remember and in this case remember
with pride and thankfulness
you look around and you offer comfort
and strength
and you look forward because as
christians
as a christian leader i i know
that the hope of the resurrection was
one of the things that
was in his life